وفي ختام مونديال قطر 20 22 وكم اعتدنا
نستعرض معكم بعض احصاءات وارقام للمره
الاخيره بعد انتصال الارجنتين على فرنسا
والتتويج بالمونديال للمره الثالثه ميسي
هو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز بالكره الذهبيه
كافضل لاعب في المونديال مرتين وتحديدا في
نسخه 2014 ومونديال 2022 اصبح ليونيل ميسي
اللاعبه اللاتيني الاكثر تسجيلا في بطوله
كاس العالم وكوبا امريكا برصيد 26 هدفا
ليتخطى البرازيلي رونالدو الظاهره الفرنسي
كيليان مبابي هو الثاني لاعب يسجل ثلاثه
اهداف وهاترك في نهائي كاس العالم بعد
ضيوفري هورس لاعب منتخب انجلترا في نهائي
مونديال
1966 اما بعد المانيا
اربعه اهداف في مباريات النهائي
بالمونديال هدف في نهائي مونديال 2018
وثلاثه اهداف في نهائي 20 22 ليصبح اللاعب
الاكثر تسجيلا في النهائيات قبل ان يتم
الرابعه والعشرين من عمره اخيرا وصل رصيده
اهداف البطوله الى 172 هدفا لتسجل رقما
قياسيا وتصبح نسخه مونديال 2022 الاكثر
تهديفا في تاريخ بطولات كاس العالم
[موسيقى]